[Music]
in terms of costumes Mark Grayson has
had it easier than most superheroes
could ever hope to because he had the
help of a professional tailor that built
his iconic outfit for free because of
super nepotism fellas like Spider-Man
Daredevil kickass and Martha Kent are
stabbing their thumbs with sewing
needles making costumes at home but
Marky Mark just needs to call up a
professional to do the whole thing I
think any superhero cosplayer wishes
they had a guy like art Rosen bomb as a
family friend instead Jacob here only
has me poor bastard so my longtime best
pal lazy Stoner Jacob and his angry
British girlfriend Molly both surprised
me by coming to town for my birthday
they stayed for a convention helped me
finish up my Deadpool suit which isn't
topical right now so I'll make that
video later and then I had one of my
trademarked ideas that I would subject
everyone else to while shopping for
fabric to make a Deadpool Mask I came
across this stretchy yellow material
that's rubbery on one side and matte on
the other Jacob jokingly said we could
use it to make an invincible costume and
then I ruined his life for it by
deciding we should do it right before
their flight home only a few days away
so with a tick and clock no real plan
and a lot of trial and error this is how
we' made an invincible costume in just
one full day no one goes on vacation to
my house they get here and then it
becomes a project because I can't
control myself and I'm horribly
dependent on my friends to make all the
stupid hairbrain schemes I come up with
at the last minute so we bought the
yellow Fabric and then found a nice
shiny blue to go with it and then I
ordered this black bodysuit from Amazon
to use as a base since we could just
attach the rest of the stuff on top of
it you really think about it all clothes
are just floppy tubes shaped like
various body parts stunning observation
I know but this also applies to gloves
you can make gloves by just tracing the
shape of your hand onto two pieces of
fabric laying them on top of each other
loading a revolver with one bullet
spinning it and placing it to your T the
intricacies of gloves come from the fact
that you have to sew pieces together
together in such a narrow space to fit
fingers sleeves are easy your red russan
crushing Grabbers are not we kept having
issues with sewing the panels together
in some Corners between the fingers so
this first attempt at gloves had a lot
of excess fabric on the inside that made
them too tight and the stitches kept
popping I ended up having to remake the
gloves entirely a second time so they
didn't cut the circulation off his
little digits if you thought that looked
hard just wait until you see the living
nightmare that is the cowl ah yes the
exposed ears hair and Chin mask a staple
of '90s and 2000 superhero costume
design it looks great on guys like
Cyclops Nightwing 9s Hawkeye and Kid
Flash a lot of superheroes have played
around with this look on occasion and
it's a pretty solid design despite not
concealing your identity for and
being weird and pointless why is the
hair got to be out what purpose does
that serve so the bad guys know he uses
a good conditioner I'm sure at some
point in 40 years will'll argue about
whether or not this is an important and
practical element of invincible costume
design in the same way that we can't get
over Superman's trunks as stylish as
this headwear is it's a in a half
to replicate in real life and I've often
seen other Invincible cosplays struggle
to pull it off too naively we thought to
ourselves that it would be just as
simple as replicating a typical Spandex
mask and cutting holes in it and slicing
the top off in theory that's all you got
to do in practice this is like trying to
make a t-shirt for your head we use the
shape and size of the Second Skin
spandex masks as a pattern to create a
little Pac-Man ghost shape on two sheets
so I could sew them together with shiny
sides in and then flip it inside out a
quick prayer to the sewing gods that I
don't this up horribly first
attempt was interesting because we
learned that this material stretches
like spandex but it sure doesn't breathe
like spandex Jacob was nearly
suffocating in this scary leather head
condom then we cut holes in it that were
slightly too big and he turned into a
horrible nightmare of creature and
terrorized everyone in the house you
scared the
dog no stop please no no no no no please
please don't you anymore on to take two
yes I'm aware I was getting kind of fat
when this video was filmed 5 months ago
I've been working out I've lost some
pounds no one asked you but you have no
social awareness and think being on the
internet makes you entitled to
anonymously run your mouth about other
people's appearances but I'll just get
it out of the way for you guy who will
never know the touch of a woman anyway
take two went better with sewing the
shape of the head but then Jacob
discovered the joys of recreational
marijuana and alcohol before filming
this and his brain cells reduced by the
good times this resulted in him making a
fatal
error wait did you cut all the way
through the back our friendship was
tested by this but ultimately he forgave
me for getting so angry I stabbed him a
little bit with a needle to punish his
foolishness I can always start again
make another kid I also did another set
of gloves everything was hard to measure
everything was a pain Jacob and Molly
had a flight the next morning so we were
cutting it close and this was one of
those work on it for 12 hours until 3
a.m. cosplays we're sewing his back up
there's too much on
me the chin kills we did way too much I
don't even want to be around anymore I
had a friend who's a professional hair
stylist come over to Wrangle Jacob's
incredibly long hair into a more Mark
Grace and appropriate shape since he was
growing it out for a Casey Jones cosplay
at a convention earlier that week he
also met Anakin Skywalker so that was
cool on our third attempt at a mask we
finally got it close enough to work with
it's not perfect but it's at least
usable the Invincible goggles look came
from a pair of reflective aviator
sunglasses that we pop the lenses out of
he glued them onto the top edge of the
mouth opening where your eyebrows would
go and then cut up under there in a way
that wouldn't show from the outside the
boots were fun shout out to Spidey
cosplayer Jake vaugh for putting
instructions for this up on his
Instagram stor so we can make these in
case my instructions are stupid you
could go check that out and also just
you know follow him he does pretty good
work we trace the shape of a morph suit
Le and make the shape of the long sock
then we cut out the bottom of it while
Jacob wore a generic slip-on shoe that
we got at Walmart you got to cut the
bottom off the shoe around the sole then
use E6000 glue or Shoe Goo to seal that
edge
then hold it down with rubber bands and
leave it for a good long while once the
glue is good to go mask off the edge of
the shoe and then hit that sole with
some plasty Dip spray to really seal the
fabric down and rubberize the bottom
bada boom good old big blue boots I
don't know how you'd get to that black
Square inside the knees look from the
earlier issues but even Mr Rosen bomb
himself decided that it wasn't a good
idea Nick that design element in later
incarnations to make the knee pad stand
out from the rest of the boot I wrapped
some some of our blue material around
craft foam and glued down the edges then
attached an elastic strap around it to
wrap around the knee and hold in place
for the more complicated parts of adding
this stupid lowercase letter I shape to
his upper body Jacob had the idea to use
plastic wrap to make a pattern and cut
the sizes right on the blue and yellow
material so we wrapped it around him
sketched out the shape and then cut it
out of the plastic then transferred that
shape to the cloth
shim what the now I do a mannequin
as you can see in the background of this
footage finally but not a tiny little
scrawny twig man little guy one shaped
like this Peter Parker you
so we'll need to improvise and by
improvise I mean we'll sew it directly
onto his body instead of mine for once
as previous cosplay videos have revealed
I have my stupid Kick-Ass pain tolerance
levels and can put dozens of pins
through my arm without noticing but
Jacob didn't unlock that power in the
skill tree so any sewing needle that
caressed his delicate flesh caused him
to let out a big
we cosplayers must suffer for our art
our body's a canvas the meat on our
bones a malleable material that we can
sculpt carve and even puncture for the
process but he wishes he
would but alas he's just can this part
with laying on two panels of blue and
three panels of yellow got to be a real
hassle we need it all Hands-On deck so
it's three sometimes four different
people all sewing it on to him at once
we all learned different threading
techniques so consistency wasn't really
an option for the threads but the Clock
Was ticking and we needed to get it done
sure it was messy on the lines but hey
the damn thing was holding together
mostly it stuck together long enough for
us to get a little photo shoot upstairs
and downstairs in the dead of night when
everyone was no longer having fun and
just wanted the suffering to finally end
all things considered it's not a bad
result for something that we put
together in such a hurry maybe we'll
Salvage what we finished here and do a
version 2 .0 at some point with a more
solid mask and cleaner stitching I'd
make the dot between the eye and the dot
the yellow I would make that little blue
space wider cuz it's like a little tight
the yellow dot on the eye being a single
piece with the mask is one of those
comic artists don't know how costumes
work in real life things like when you
see Spider-Man's mask lenses wrinkled
when he takes it off even though they're
made of glass there's no way in hell
that would work in real life because the
fabric wouldn't sit still and lay flat
on the flat like that unless he had like
a row of magnets or velcro holding it
down ours is just a mask that stops at
the neck I sent Jacob home with all the
Fabrics that we used for this so he
could revisit the old ironically named
neple baby superhero that won our hearts
by living in a world with consequences
the suit may have started to fall apart
after Jacob took it home and we may have
accidentally sewn parts of it to a
pillow and had to cut the pillow out and
we may have stabbed Jacob several times
and we may have just barely made it to
the airport on time the next morning
while sleep deprived and cranky and and
I may have stressed out all the people
closest to me with one of my hairbrain
schemes and a ridiculously unreasonable
lastminute project idea that I wanted to
put together just so I could have a
topical upload at the time of invincible
season 2 releasing but you know what it
was totally worth
it Robert Kirkman if you see this video
can you give us free copies of the
compendium as a reward for going through
this horrible horrible train wreck
nightmare I always get mad at YouTube
for not putting my videos in the
subscription box as people will comment
finally Xavier uploads again after all
these years not knowing three other
videos came out within the last month
already so maybe that stupid Bell icon
thing will help you remember I exist if
you want other ways to support the
channel you can always go hit up that
patreon for early videos and exclusive
stuff because it's just a dollar I'm not
kidding it's only $1 Isn't that cool if
everyone who watched this video donated
$1 a month I'd be able to afford a house
for myself so that would be that would
be really cool you can also check out
our merch on Tu or just buy some of my
random stuff on eBay I have a pretty
substantial collection of old toys that
are still in the box in perfect
condition so go take a look in case you
find something you like and lastly since
this is a YouTube video and you probably
play fortnite drop my Creator code
Xavier GM next time you buy a silly
dance or a cool character skin really
helps me out see you next
[Music]
time